just got word that Senator Coons who is
shaking his hand they're giving him a
hug
you know why is giving a hug because
senator Coons offered in a spirit of
bipartisanship to vote present change
his vote to present which would allow
this nomination to go from the committee
to the Senate floor we just witnessed
the bipartisan hug there as they all
file out of the room essentially what
this means was the vote was tied 10 to
10 they were stuck Coons changed his
vote to present instead of No and now
the nomination of CIA director Mike
Pompeo to be Secretary of State goes to
goes to the Senate floor and they do
have enough votes let's bring in our
senior political analyst for Hume with
this breaking news happening Britain
your thoughts on this and the whole kind
of moment that this was getting a
Secretary of State nomination out of the
Foreign Policy Committee well I think
Brett that they had a number of options
they could have rivo today after Johnny
Isakson got back from his funeral they
could add another meeting and voted
again it could have been reported out of
the committee with an unfavorable
recommendation which gets it to the
floor unless Democrats wouldn't go along
with that which would seem a little odd
but I think what happened is about as
good an outcome as you could expect for
the Republicans and for this nominee
under the circumstances but it's
characteristic of the Senate kind of at
its best that that member of the other
party who is and who will probably Koons
why almost certainly vote no on the
floor but allowing the nomination to
proceed for the full consideration by
the Senate is it's pretty much in the
tradition of the way the Senate is
usually operated so I think it's a good
development all the way around just saw
Senator Paul leave the committee room
they're bred and obviously he had a
change of heart after meeting with the
president and also meeting with CIA
director and nominee Pompeyo Mike well I
think in the case of Rand Paul he's
idiosyncratic he's one of a kind and he
votes what he considers to be his
conscience in this case however I think
you know you must have had in the back
of his mind that Donald Trump is popular
in the state of Kentucky where he hails
from
and that if his vote were the decisive
vote that were actually had the effect
of killing the nomination which I don't
think would have happened but if it had
been that would have been problematic
for him so he so he gets treated to a
meeting with the president and a meeting
with nominee Pompeo and he gets some
bland assurances from from Pompeo that
he will support the president's policies
how can he do otherwise and and changes
his vote so he can go home and say well
I extracted these promises and now I'm
satisfied and presumably his conditions
will be happy and he doesn't work yeah
what does this say they'll bread about
where we are in that you have this
nominee who's the CIA director who just
got back from Pyongyang meeting with Kim
jong-un as the delicate dance of getting
this meeting potentially with the
president and the North Korean leader is
still being worked out having this issue
and obviously kind of a speed bump along
the way to confirmation it is very much
bread a sign of the times we live in an
age of partisanship on a level that I've
never seen before and I've been doing
this around Washington for about about
40 some years now and I've never seen
quite like this I mean you had Democrats
know perfectly well that might pump hail
on the face of it is perfectly qualified
he's you know you've served in the in
the Congress for a long time it's
glittering academic credentials as CIA
director you don't have any real
objections about him there he clearly
qualified as you note he's been engaged
in these negotiations very important
negotiations with North Korea already
and you had things like jeanne shaheen
the Democratic senator from New
Hampshire saying she was going to vote
against him because of his position on
abortion that's almost laughable at any
other time but that is where we are
profound partisanship and a constituency
for many of these Democrats who will be
satisfied with nothing less than all-out
opposition to Donald Trump and every
single thing he does even if these
things are otherwise would normally go
forward without objection you know it is
said of Donald Trump that he is that he
has stepped all over all kinds of
in our country and perhaps he has but he
has induced his opponents to do the same
thing and this behavior toward this
nominee is but one example of that
that's right and last thing as we look
at this state visit by the French
president and his wife obviously they'll
have this big state dinner there are no
Democrats invited to that state dinner
that seems to be a first as well yeah
that's another norm that has been
ignored I think I think that's
regrettable but I would say this about
the relationship with Emmanuel macron he
is an important ally for this president
and you know we've had a long alliance
with the French going back to the
Revolutionary War and it is it is it is
stood for a long time but it has not
been untroubled and you may remember
Brett what what fits the French gave :
pal as he was trying to wound up support
in the UN for a second resolution to
authorize the Iraq war and the French
Foreign Minister was trailing him around
and arriving everywhere he just left in
the country to try to talk people out of
going along with the u.s. so the
relationship has had some serious
problems in recent years and the fact
that it seems so strong now despite some
obvious disagreements you know the the
Paris climate treaty being one of them
and the and of course the the the Iran
nuclear deal being the other it is still
an important achievement for the
president that he seems to have come to
this relationship with one of our most
important European allies at a time when
the president can use whatever support
in Europe he can get right it's always
good to have you all especially on these
days for your expertise Brett thanks
well thanks Brett